so once I found out there was a sex
robot Factory I obviously had to go
here's why I went to the sex robot
Factory I am fascinated by the question
is this impossible standard of beauty
the women are killing themselves to try
to achieve is that even what all men
want I am delighted to report back that
the answer is no not only did half of
the dolls that were ordered have pubic
hair the customers spent an extra $1,400
for it I spent $1,400 getting mine
lasered off this is proof we are not
communicating we got to start talking to
each other you guys it will save us
money but that wasn't enough I still
wanted to see what they were doing with
the robot bodies what if they were
making these impossible to achieve by
that be bad for society right I
especially wanted to see the boobs
because in my head every guy wants the
same kind of boob right giant double D
little tiny perky nipple no no there's a
wall of nipples 38 different kinds one
of the most popular oblong one of them
look like a piece of caramel fell on the
floor bestseller great news ladies
whatever shape your nipple there is a
man out there who will pay top dollar
so I found this fascinating and I start
talking the guy who puts the nipples on
the robots right it takes him 24 hours
to put on one pair of nipples I'm like
what's the problem mr. potato hut that
shit let's go and he said it's actually
a very meticulous process because they
work very hard to make sure the nipples
are uneven because for something to look
human it has to have flaws if something
is too symmetrical it actually looks
creepy take that Ryan Gosling space that
was great news for me and you guys might
know why some of you might not know this
but I had eating disorders until I was
in my late 20s and as a result my boobs
grew in different sizes that's a side
effect for people and they have eating
disorders sometimes as your boobs grow
in a little bit differently I had to get
three surgeries to get them straightened
out one was bigger than the other one
one was higher than the other one they
they look like from the same general
family one was just like a shittier
version of the other one it was like
Alec Baldwin and Stephen Baldwin I kind
of just wanted to Stephens you know
or to Alex I'll take either at this
point and I was always so embarrassed
about them because before I'd get with a
guy I felt like I had to explain when he
was about to see I'd have to prepare him
you know I'd be like do you like
baseball and golf
do you like young women and old men you
don't have to choose big Salvador Dali
fan so the tragic irony of this whole
thing is that they're still not even
because one of the surgeons made a
mistake and they cut through a muscle I
know never get an operation by the
airport red flag I feel like I probably
should have saw and I hated them for the
last couple years I hated them because I
felt ashamed my whole thing is you know
accept who you are love your body and I
felt like a hypocrite because I had
these implants in so I resented having
all that work done for the longest time
until a couple years ago when I got in a
really bad snowboarding accident and I
broke my shoulder and I go into the
surgeon and he's like I don't understand
this injury makes no sense I see this
all the time when people fall forward on
a snowboard
they break their nose they get a
concussion you only broke your shoulder
how did this happen and in that moment I
realized that I bounced off my tits
and then my fate should save my life
[Applause]